I'm very happy to introduce the next
amazing become very curly he is the
professor at Brown University and he is
well known for his work that helped to
lay the foundation on multi-factor
synchronization and the theory of
distributed computing and for his
amazing work she has won numerous
distinction he is the recipient of the
Dykstra prize in distributed beauty in
2003 for his work on wait three years
synchronization and then in 2004 he
received a girdle price for applying
topology to the theory of the
distributed computing in 2008 he
received the ESCA influential paper
award and then he received the Dijkstra
prize again in 2012 for his this time
for his work on transactional memory and
then in 2013 he received awarded much
McDowell Award so this is joint work
with Barbara Liskov and Luba shreya Roth
who have agreed to handle any awkward or
difficult questions
did they arise so the paper itself is
currently lives on archive but it'll
appear in the next vldb now as you all
know distributed computing is often
describes in terms of adversaries so you
describe a an algorithm a system or so
on in terms of the adversaries who are
trying to cause mischief and how
powerful they are and what they are
allowed and not allowed to do now
classical distributed computing the
adversary is typically the cute and the
senses you know fairly abstract very
limited it can make control timing you
know what do you do if messages are late
what if they're out of order what if
your components crash
what if messages are lost you know you
think about you know what would the
adversary do in this particular case oh
we can fix it because you know we do
something or other at the very limit
there's Byzantine failures which aren't
although technically we say that they're
malicious but really we call them
Byzantine because we're too lazy to
enumerate all of the possible failure
modes but in some greater sense we're
not really worried about that there are
gremlins attacking the sensors on an
airplane wing no really it's just kind
of a shorthand for saying yeah we don't
really know what the failure modes are
so we'll just assume that they're that
they're bad now given this we're given
against such an adversary usually we're
attacking very small precisely stated
technical problems like consensus set
agreement renaming you know there's
three or four a problem is that people
have built careers publishing policy
papers on different ways to to solve
these things but everything is you know
very constrained and small and you know
precise and abstract but since then the
world has changed and our notion of the
adversary has changed so instead of
having kind of unpredictable failures
there are actually
all people and agents who are causing a
problems the nature of the attack we're
not worried they fun you know like the
Farsi you know you should be flattered
anyway the so modern adversaries have
more than one way of attacking and they
will attack you in ways you didn't
anticipate Byzantine failures you say
well we've got a piss and we don't know
what value is coming in in this case
we're worried about all kinds of subtle
attacks examples are you know
side-channel attacks you know things
like SGX turns out to be vulnerable to
all of these look ahead caching effects
no meltdown inspector or things like
that
rootkits for Bach Keynes there's a whole
repertoire of exotic attacks that people
advised you know some of these attacks
were a device by by people here the
world is much more complicated into
place the kinds of attacks that you need
to worry about are much more subtle and
indirect and the problems that we're
trying to solve are much harder we're
not interested in doing consensus we're
interested in building you know a
society we're bitten we want to build a
an economy we want to build the bank a
company and things like that and so the
the world is much more complicated than
it used to be and we need to rethink how
we think about distributed computing in
the face of this kind of much more
fearsome adversary than and we're used
to so let me give you an example of
something that we'd like to do we call
this adversarial Commerce because we
couldn't think of a more glamorous than
name so here we have one in one party a
bob who owns a theatre and wants to sell
tickets Carol here wants to buy theater
tickets and Alice is a broker who
handles who is willing to make the
market
and in return for a small commission she
will sell Bob's tickets to with the
Kerala and this is an example of the
kind of commerce that we would like to
do this is every serial commerce because
none of these parties know each other
and or trust each other yeah that's not
an important aspect this is just a kind
of an example and you know specific show
that's far enough in advance that we're
not worried about it could be
synchronous or asynchronous you know
we're not interested in this example and
get kind of that level of detail this is
just an example of something where we
have an intermediary you know we have
people you know Bob and Carol don't deal
with each other directly they they go
through atlas and you know any
implementation would probably be
synchronous no but but that's not the
level which I want to worry about this
problem so they want to do a deal and
the deal is pretty much what you would
expect in this context so Carol has 101
Bitcoin so he gives him Dallas Alice
takes her one Bitcoin Commission and
forwards it to to Bob and then Bob sends
back the tickets
and then everyone is happy so this is
how this is kind of the naive abstract
version of the kind of deal that we want
to do now of course I'm papering over
and skating over all kinds of
complexities traps and so on but ideally
this is the sort of thing we want to do
now before we go any further I want to
mention that this is not the same as a
cross chain swap the when we first
started working on this people said oh
crusty and swaps we know how to do that
you know what's what's the fuss but this
kind of deal cannot be expressed as a
swap and if you try you'll end up with
something that isn't a swap and the
reason is that alice is using Carol's
money to pay Bob so this is a hallowed
principle of modern finance that you
sell something you don't own and and by
the time everything is straightened out
you end up with your commission but if
this were a swap then Alice would have
to have the money to buy the tickets in
a swap and then she would do another
swap to sell it but we're doing the
entire thing as one sort of atomic unit
and so this is not a swap this is you
know we're going to steal ideas from the
atomic swap world right and left but
technically this is not a swap a swap is
a special case of what I want to talk
about now basically a swap you directly
send an asset from one party to another
here there's indirection you know I'd
sent you an asset and you send it to
someone else and the indirect the entire
indirect thing is part of the deal it's
related but not the same thing because
payment networks are really sort of a
series of kind of atomic is sort of
series of hops and then you kind of
atomically so this encompasses payment
networks but that isn't kind of the main
thing that we're trying to do
except I'm still studying computing what
the difference between this because you
could do an atomic swap but the coins
end up split over two accounts but here
you're saying that a is a separate house
doesn't Ellis doesn't have any money
when she starts out yeah nothing to swap
with Bob to get those tickets why would
you give Alice that that money Alice's
role is to act as a broker if if Karen
if camera land Bob could deal together
they would cut out the middleman you
know like what it's like you go to
Airbnb and the owner will say next time
you come to town talk to me directly so
you know modern commerce would crash to
a halt yeah yeah yeah Alice has no
interest in introducing them to each
other and so you know the this idea of
kind of leveraging and selling things
that you don't own and paying for with
money that you don't own is no it's a
good thing actually
okay what can go wrong here well sort of
all the obvious things could go wrong so
we can end up with Bob sends out his
tickets and doesn't get paid and again
you know we're living in this
libertarian paradise where there is no
recourse and so if this happens you know
there's nothing about can do we can't
call the police because you know who
knows who Allison and Carol actually are
maybe they're the same person that's
unacceptable
symmetrically you know if Carol who'd be
swindled and the others you know could
take her her money you know we don't
that's not considered an acceptable
outcome it could be that Allison ends up
with both of these things even if Alice
it's honest and of course Alice's as a
broker he's concerned about a reputation
no she unlike the others who are kind of
ephemeral you know he's worried that
she'll get a reputation of being someone
who was unreliable or steals things so
now she's got to figure out how to
return these things in order to preserve
her a good name as a broker and so you
know that's not acceptable either one
thing that is acceptable is maybe
nothing happens you know they try but
they're unable to reach a deal and
everybody ends up with where they
started and that's considered acceptable
although it's not preferred so if we try
to do a deal and somehow it breaks and
everybody ends up a hole then well in
real life this is an ideal because
people paid fees they had resources
locked up for brief periods so they're
not gonna be happy but it's not
considered a disaster now we just view
this as a price of doing business so
this would be considered an OK outcome
even if we don't like it
but I thought your specifically trying
to rule out Bob and Carol finding out
each other's identity well the we're
sort of assuming that it the deal we're
not talking about how how the market is
set up somehow they find each other you
know maybe Bob and Carol find Alice
through craigslist or something like
that that would not be considered all
I'm talking about is in the end we want
the we want we want they but the money
in the tickets to change hands and we
want Alice to get her a fair a
commission and I haven't talked about
how to do this yet and the thing to
remember is that one thing when how come
that is not acceptable as Alice doesn't
get paid yeah yeah yeah yeah no no
there's lots of other things that are
considered unacceptable but but so far
the only two acceptable scenarios or
everybody gets what they want
or no but nothing happens or no asset
change yeah yeah but then but that's
that's a separate issue after the deal
is over we're worried about what happens
after everything quiets down if nothing
changes then you say well that was a
waste of time but it's not considered a
disaster if after the deal he or she can
make the deal yeah but that's the
question about the mechanism not about
what you're trying to that would be a
fail that mechanism but anybody I don't
want to talk about identities here
because then that's a distraction from
where I'm trying to go with this
oh yeah yeah yeah I should mention that
the tickets and the coins both live on
separate watch kings you know this is
the future where everything has a
blockchain know this would be relatively
easy if they were all in the same
walking well I've been a little bit
evasive about what the what kind of
atomicity we want because because I want
to talk about that at length soon but
but but the net result is we want to
guarantee that everybody is happy at the
at the end and I'm going to kind of
drill down and make that more precise as
we go along because it turns out that
actually trying to specify what this
means it's more complicated than then
you might think yeah yeah so you know
the idea is that you know you have a
world with lots and lots of block chains
each box chain has its own resources we
want to trade the things that are in
different block chains we want to do not
just you know these sort of direct swaps
but we want to do these kind of indirect
brokered deals and you know things like
we want to do things like auctions we
want to do complicated second-price
Dutch Flemish auctions
well that's those are different models
and what I'm studiously avoiding saying
whether we're in a synchronous or
asynchronous model because I want to
focus on correctness conditions that
apply to both when we talk about
mechanisms which I'm actually not going
to talk about in this talk but Mark
barber talked about some of that earlier
then in the paper has a mechanism that
works in a synchronous model and then
the CBC mechanism that that works in an
asynchronous model
everything at this level is not
probabilistic yet so you know I'll talk
a little bit about finality at the end
you know whether when something is
finished is it really done or is it we
have done with overwhelming probability
that kind of thing
so the the tickets we assume are SAR
certificates that can be redeemed for
tickets and we assume there's some
mechanism that means that you can tell
whether you have a ticket and when you
bring this ticket to a theater they
actually let you in the mechanism could
be probabilistic if ya if you're willing
to live with that so it could be at this
level description it could be either
probabilistic or deterministic where
probabilistic means true with an
overwhelming probability which is a
common thing in the world
so in general the focus is we have a
bunch of parties and they want to create
assets that's all they want to do you
know they want to send you have
something of value they want to do these
complicated exchanges where they end up
it's something else of value and we want
to figure out how to make God make that
happen we want to do things like
multi-step transfers you know we want to
do all these sophisticated financial
instruments including you know the
ticket brokering example where you use
money that you don't have to buy
something you don't own and then you end
up with the you know having done the
transfer and collecting a commission
each asset lives on its own database or
blockchain I'm going to describe this in
terms of blockchain but really if
blockchains ran out without a business
tomorrow everything I say would still be
valid if you replace blockchains with
whatever you know secure it contra proof
database technology that would replace
it so this isn't really about blockchain
this is about how you do trading in an
environment where nobody trusts each
other and you can't enforce anything
block chains are a convenient way to
implement this but it's not not really
essential
and of course the parties are autonomous
nobody knows who nobody trusts anybody
nobody knows who they are if somebody
rips you off you have no recourse so you
know it's a you know harsh environment
in that in that respect
so what I'm going to talk about is that
what it means for one of these
adversarial Commerce deals to be correct
the paper also talks about mechanisms
for how to implement this which I'm not
gonna have time to talk about but I'm
really going to talk about how we need
to rethink classical notions of
correctness so the closest thing to what
I'm describing would be a distributed
atomic transaction in the database but
classical databases are different
because you don't really expect
Byzantine behavior from your components
you don't that you you can often kind of
enforce compliance but here you can't
force anybody to do anything to say this
is the protocol we should all follow I
can't force you to follow the protocol I
can maybe detect if you deviate from the
protocol but a situation where if we you
cooperate it will be to our benefit but
everybody would be perfectly happy to
pick everyone else's pocket and so we
need to find a way that allows people to
benefit and cooperate even though we
don't know anything about the motives or
capabilities of our counterparties
so classical distributed transactions
are often describes in terms of the the
so called acid properties now these acid
properties like all these try limits we
hear about don't really hold up well
under scrutiny so basically these are
kind of mismatched poorly defined
properties yeah a little bit like our
friend friendly trial trial Emma's but
I'm going to use these as to drive the
narrative because these are familiar to
a lot of people we can kind of skate
over some of the you know
inconsistencies and of and bakery so
it's good way to organize the story but
don't take these terms too literally
because they're like I said if you tried
to make them precise that there's all my
difficulties so these are you know every
database book in the world says well
what did transactions do will they
satisfy this acid their properties and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to go
over each of these properties and talk
about how they change when we put them
into an adversarial environment
so the old adversary was happy to deal
with this a new adversary is unhappy
with this and you know the problem with
this really starts at the root so I'm
going to give you a failure model so the
idea here is I'm going to say that
what could a party do well they could be
compliant
that means they take an oath and they
stick to it you know like like these you
know Roman heroes they say you know
we're we're going to follow the protocol
and we're going to do exactly what what
it says if you don't comply you could
Evi eight from the protocol which means
you can do anything
so deviating members can you do
absolutely anything they want and you
can't stop them and you can't even
always detect it
I think that's it so there are lots and
lots of a much more elaborate protocol
much more elaborate models where we say
well some of them are Byzantine and some
of them are altruistic and some of them
are crafty and rational yeah and we you
know we saw even other more elaborate
things in earlier talks today now I
don't dispute that there are contexts
where these more complicated models make
perfect sense but if you think about
adversarial Commerce it doesn't make any
sense to say well Alice Bob and Carols
ticket example we're going to assume
that 51 percent of them are correct or
67 percent are correct Alice and Bob
could be the same could be the same
person doing a civil attack on Carol so
we're not going to make any assumptions
about the number of deviating parties
everybody could be deviating we can't
guarantee you know you call a few people
on Craigslist and say let's do this
swamp you can't assume that one of one
of them is correct so we're going to
assume any number of deviating parties
you watch ants are not parties is
something their Ledger's of some kind
movie think of blocking we're going to
assume that the block chains are live
incorrect because they're kind of
passive elements so so is it's perfectly
okay that you can assume that the 51% of
the Bitcoin miners are honest because
otherwise you couldn't do anything but
you can't assume that 51% of the people
you're doing your drug deal with are
honest no no no I just used a database
to emphasize the fact that this is not a
blockchain I don't care about the
blockchain technology at this level all
we care is this tamper proof live and it
does what it's supposed to do
in particular I don't care about well
it's not for the time being I don't care
what flavor blockchain it is although
we're going to need finality in some way
this vision thing because it seems to me
that they the guy that blades to follow
the protocol are honest so the
difference is that well so Byzantine
corresponds roughly to non-compliant you
know say if you're non-compliant you can
do anything we don't assume that
non-compliant are rational we don't
assume anybody's rational you know we
don't all we say is either you conform
to the protocol or you do something else
you know we're not we're not judging
we're not doing moral perfect okay to
say is to say just say that they're
Byzantine but you know Byzantine could
be as a synonym for net for
non-compliant but the problem is you say
Byzantine that people say what about
altruistic or what about this the other
thing so I trust you not to be confused
about this but you know these others
[Laughter]
okay so first thing is atomicity you
know atomicity is kind of the coin of
the realm in here and roughly speaking
you know this is not going to be a
formal talk you know you say either
everything happens or nothing happens so
the net effect is as if everybody got
what they wanted or it's as if you know
no assets change the hands and this is
what we mean when we say we commit or we
abort the transaction now the problem is
that it is literally impossible to
enforce all-or-nothing properties in an
environment where we have autonomous
agents who cannot who can do anything
they feel like you know if nothing else
a incompetent deviating party might try
to steal something fail and have its
assets slashed and that's perfectly okay
but that's neither all nor is it nothing
so we need to be much more careful about
what we expect to happen because you
might be tempted to say okay maybe just
it's all nothing for the conforming
parties but even that doesn't work
because the deviating party might just
do an airdrop and give everyone money
and if you require the warring parties
to refuse that then nobody will you know
buy your system so we want to be a
little bit more careful about what what
happens so let's put this into two
subsidiary properties
so we'll say liveness says if everybody
conforms then all the transfers happen
this is sort of the commit case you know
this is sort of the minimum you want if
everybody behaves and you know the
network behaves and etcetera etcetera
then everything happens yeah
you just the airdrop happens in a
separate transaction well but but then
you're going to go down this kind of
rathole say well what about this
situation what about that situation what
about that situation so we're gonna come
up with a formulation that says that you
know the bad guys can do anything they
want and you know I'll answer that in
like one or two slides so if if all the
parties are conforming then all of the
transfers take place you know that's
sort of the the minimum reasonable
liveness property you can ask for it
it's also the maximum safety
it says if some of the parties deviate
no conforming party ends up worse off
and I know most of you are looking at
this term worse off with alarm and
saying you know this looks like you know
looks like trouble and I'll say
something about what that worse off
means but the idea is that if you
conform the protocol that you use to do
this deal had better ensure that as long
as you conform you can't be heated you
know it doesn't say that it guarantees
that you get that Carol gets her tickets
but this guarantee the Carol doesn't end
up worse off than when she started
it's every party can decide for
themselves what it means to be worse off
so like suppose I can get you for you
know five seconds I can get you to
commit to like buying a dollar for like
you know ninety nine ninety five Euro
cents or something and then at the end
of second I can like decide whether I
want to do that that option has value
for me it costs you you had to like lock
up to some money so if that affords
would you consider yourself worse off if
it aborts your not worse off because
then you were before you might be full
of a regret and gnashing your teeth but
you're not objectively worse off at the
end than you were you know what we're
learning things like things action fees
and annoyance and time wasting ignoring
the time value
we're ignoring the time value of money
in this case because when we talk when
you when you're looking at mechanisms
you'll want to say oh you know the swap
is correct according to these criteria
but I don't like it because optionality
because of all these other things that's
well I'm gonna put that as a performance
issue which I'm not going to discuss but
you know these correctness conditions
are not the only things that you want
I'm just saying that the this is how you
transform the baseline classical
correctness conditions to make sense in
this there are plenty of other things
that you care about you know does this
work in a model I consider you know I if
you don't believe in a synchronous model
then does this work in a synchronous
model I'm gonna go in detail about what
what are acceptable in the end what's
acceptable what's not acceptable is more
or less up to the individual no so if
you buy tickets and I give you different
tickets and once I advertise you can say
oh these are better tickets than I
ordered yeah yes I'll take it no I don't
like these tickets I'm going to abort
the via deal everyone knows their own
utility function and they can decide
whether to continue or so for the deal
to go through everybody has to be happy
and anybody can veto the deal is if
you're conforming anybody can veto the
deal if you're not if you deviate from
the protocol then we don't care what
happens to you you deserve what whatever
cruel fate that falls on you Versalles
completely well I don't understand
itself some means from one to possibly
know if anybody other than you some
could be we have no assumptions about
the number of deviating parties and so
if a coalition of deviating parties you
know conspires against you you know they
can't make you worse off deviates we
don't care you know because we only
protect the honest conforming parties
so of course you know what do you what
do we mean when we say worse off in this
case so this is I'm going to explain
this using kind of cookbook game theory
so I have to admit that everything I
know about game theory I learned on the
streets I was never given proper
instruction and in in this stuff so I'm
going to use very kind of simple
language and those of you who know more
about game theory should feel free to
chime in and I probably won't be able to
ask any questions I'll refer them to my
co-authors so approach you know a
cooperative a deal is a cooperative game
everybody works together and you end up
with something in the end you spend
things and you receive things a protocol
is just a suggested strategy so I said
okay everybody we want to sell these
tickets this is the protocol that you
follow you know maybe it involves hash
locks maybe it involves a CBC maybe you
don't know this but it involves
protocols of strategy we're gonna assume
that parties can form coalition's and
they commit to a common strategy this is
because there may be simple attacks some
collection of parties may actually be
the same party you know they may be
under the control of the same evil lab
on the villain probably know the result
is called the payoff so you play this
game you either follow the common
strategy and conform or you deviate from
the strategy again you end up with some
kind of payoff so I'm going to talk
about the different payoffs and give
them kind of names for classes of
roughly equivalent payoffs you think if
you you can can't just add to you in the
middle
yes yeah yeah and if you deviate it at
any point you're considered to be
deviating and anybody can deviate at any
time this is why it's important to say
for the beginning that any number can
deviate we can't we don't put an
assumption you know it just doesn't seem
realistic to place a limit on the number
of deviating parties so as long as you
yourself are honest they protocol better
guarantee that you're not don't can't
end up worse off so one sorry I
shouldn't have said that there was no
honest there's conforming or not
conforming and so honest is you know I'm
making a moral judgment that I shouldn't
be doing no no you're not conforming to
be conforming you have to conform all
the way through
so one is so this is the party one
outcome is you get paid something an
incoming asset is transferred but none
of the outgoing assets are transferred
so this called freeride because you're
getting something for nothing that's one
possible thing that could happen if the
protocol goes wrong another one is sort
of what we call discount which says that
all of the incoming assets that I was
promised were transferred into my
ownership but only some of my outgoing
transfers were happened so in other
words I paid this was cheaper than I
expected you know I expected I would get
a bunch of incoming assets I expected I
would pay a bunch of outgoing assets I
was okay with that but turns out I paid
less than I expected that's another
class of possible outcomes a deal is the
expected normal outcome where you get
all of your incoming assets and you pay
all of your outgoing assets this is you
know classical transaction commits
scenario No Deal is classical
transaction abort scenario no assets
come in or out you end up with exactly
what you started with and finally no the
one you've been waiting for is some
incoming asset is not transferred you
don't get paid everything you want but
you some outgoing asset is transferred
so in other words you weren't paid
everything you were promised and but you
had to pay yourself and this is the kind
of a chaotic outcome
now you know this may or may not be
acceptable probably not but it says that
you know what I agreed I would be paid
this and I agreed I would pay that but
what happened was I got some of this and
some of that and you know this is a
total mess
so yeah yeah yeah yeah no no that is you
can sort of flip it around and and you
know flip the ours around if I'm
unloading toxic waste then I think you
know I'm not sure what happens if you
have both gold and toxic wastes in the
same transaction but I'm sure it could
be done strictly positive because if
it's zero well then why bother is with
Europe we've only realised this with
zero halfway transaction I'm gonna sue
me here that it that the the values are
kind of fixed there's lots of ways you
can kind of extend and twiddle with the
model but I want to stick with something
as simple at this point because I'm
trying to convince you you could be
thinking about things this way and I
want to encourage you to go off and add
all of these extensions so we want to
rank these things so deal is better than
no deal terms of being better off
because otherwise why would you agree to
do this in the first place if you didn't
consider doing the trade better than not
doing the trade if this were the other
way around you wouldn't have signed up
for the transaction to begin with
discount is better than deal because you
get the same thing but you pay less so
you know this seems pretty
straightforward a free ride is better
than no deal because you didn't pay
anything but you got something so in
this case you end up unchanged here
you're unchanged except you get
something extra and I don't want to
argue about whether free rider or a deal
are better because you can think of
scenarios that work either way and it
doesn't really matter and underwater is
it kind of the chaotic outcome where you
know something's happen is all the
things that don't happen and what I'm
gonna say is well everything above here
is acceptable so if you end up in any
state up here at the end of the a deal
then you're no worse off than you were
before
and you're actually you know in some
cases must be better off so this is kind
of no worse off and these are better
this is better off under water is hard
to say this is application the dependent
probably that's not acceptable but there
may be special cases where it is
acceptable so the acceptability of
underwater outcomes is application
dependent like you might say well I was
expecting to get three assets and I
suspect in spend three other assets but
if I get two and I paid two I'm okay
with that as well
that would be acceptable or you might
say well that's not acceptable you know
I want the the full deal or nothing at
all and so you know you you can design
your protocols can pick either of those
into account yeah yeah so I think this
is from the point of view of an
individual party you can say I'm happy
with this outcome because I got
everything I asked for it well I got
more than I asked for in the st. and
then same deal you might say I'm not
totally unhappy with this because you
know I paid and I didn't get anything so
this this is from your point of view and
it's also the particularly with these
underwater things that's your individual
choice so all of these protocols are
going to have a stage where you sit you
look at the outcome and say am i happy
with this yes III I want to proceed you
know no I don't like this outcome I'm
pulling the plug and you know this
reflects the fact that nobody trusts
anybody else everybody has to make their
own decision about everybody has their
own objective function that only they
know
why this cannot be formulated as
old-school distributed dust because
old-school distributed tasks didn't
think about these kinds of we are using
tricks from old-school distributed tasks
but we're putting them together in a new
way because you are some people have
been doing this since the ancient
Babylonians but we have black canes but
one technical assumption I'm going to
put here is that acceptability is
monotonic if I view a an outcome is
being satisfactory it's also
satisfactory if I get more or I pay less
definition worse off always required to
be below but you're saying that that is
application dependent that is
application dependent in practice I
think it's almost always going to be
below No Deal
there might be special cases where you
can say well I was you know I negotiated
really good deal something fell apart
but I can still get an okay deal and we
don't want to rule that out but it's
really kind of a marginal if you rule it
out then people will say oh but you're
too inflexible if you let it in people
say well that never happens
it's a zero-sum game where initially
every player has some let's say value
and then the protocol distributes the
value and then you can clearly divide
each player's utility by different you
can do that except I don't think it's a
zero-sum game if you and I are trading
or something we both have to feel we're
but we're better off otherwise we
wouldn't be doing the trade so so it's
not zero-sum but it is a it is a game in
in that sense so I've been made a
deliberate attempt to avoid using
utility functions and kind of argue on a
more informal level but you could
totally go in and put utility functions
the Greek letters on all of these things
but you know I'm we're trying to make an
effort to be intuitive but but waiting
at heart you're right this is how you
would do it if in other cultures okay
consistency I'm gonna have to speed up a
little bit so consistency is kind of a
odd person out here if this has to do
with application-specific constraints
are respected this is my mind kind of a
confused property which i think is put
in there only so they could make the
acid acronym so I'm going to use this as
a way to sneak in application specific
considerations and the idea here is that
let me remind you what a strong Nash
equilibrium is I'm sure some of you know
this better than I do you know the idea
is everybody there's a default strategy
that everyone is requested to follow but
if some coalition deviates you know some
coalition commits the deviating together
then it won't improve its payoff so
following the default strategy is a
strong Nash equilibrium if it satisfies
this property and so because that's a
lot of words I'll just say that the
protocol is a strong Nash equilibrium
although technically
make sense they so conforming to the
protocol should be as strong Nash
equilibrium because otherwise no one is
going to follow it you know here for
example is a diagram where everybody has
a some kind of asset that they want to
trade with everyone else
for example you know Alice wants to send
Bitcoin to Felix and there's a theorem
that you can prove that if we have a
protocol that ensures that no conforming
party ends up underwater that's a strong
Nash equilibrium if and only if this
directed graph is strongly connected and
I'm not going to prove that here because
I don't have time to prove it but you
know what I'll say is that if it's false
then there's some sub graph that absorbs
assets but doesn't produce them so
assets transferred from here go there
but nothing that comes back and so
strongly actually equilibrium you would
say well I'm going to defect and just
not not send this asset and pretend I
did and now I'm better off these people
can't complain because they can't
communicate with anyone and so then
that's a kind of moral hazard so that
better payoff to defect so it's clearly
not a any kind of Nash equilibrium if
the digraph is strongly connected and a
coalition exceed you know this the other
direction it gives a better payoff by
deviating then we can prove that some
conforming party must be under water and
again I'm not going to prove that but
you can if you want means given any two
vertices there's a directed path from
one to the other
yeah everybody's on a cycle no because I
think you can beyond you could have
disconnect the graph word with two
cycles and that's not strongly connected
so it's got to be every vertex can reach
every other vertex so does this mean the
model can't accommodate like a job
like if I do some for you if I buy lunch
from you and you're gonna call the
police and put me in jail if I don't pay
you then that would be that would not be
strongly connected if you look only at
the payment that's because there's a
hidden the payment you're saying with
the sandwich that you gave me isn't
shown on the graph so so yeah we we
don't we're assuming that all value
transfers happen on block chains you can
generalize it to say well maybe we have
hidden transfers too but you know just
technically because want to keep things
simple we're assuming that everything is
all all asset transfers happen on some
chain there's more to life than that any
formal model isolation this is no
transaction seized in other intermediate
states this is where we get serialize
ability and things like that problem in
the blockchain world serializability
doesn't make any sense because if you
look at things like time - like
protocols everybody they're interacting
through these kind of cautious steps
where I'll do something and we do you do
something and then you do something you
know like these old cowboy movies the so
serialize ability isn't the analog of
isolation in this case what is the
analog is escrow is a lot like locking a
data structure so in order to convince
you I'm serious about giving you the
money for the tickets I need to put my
coins in escrow in order to convince you
that I'm serious about selling the
tickets I need to put the tickets in
escrow and the meaning of risk if I can
revoke the escrow and grab the money and
run then you probably shouldn't be doing
a deal with me so the equivalent of
isolation is basically that assets
placed in escrow can't be unlocked until
the deal is complete by unlocked I mean
either refunded or transferred to the
counterparty you're not allowed to move
things around out of escrow in the
middle of a a deal in a way that pulls
out the rug from the deal
this is a definition this is what if you
can revoke escrow in the middle of a
deal then it's not an escrow it's
impossible to construct these deals with
that escrow so that's something you need
to prove where it's I'm saying that I
know I believe that's true but I'm not
willing to prove it I'm just going to
assume it here yeah condition locking
locking is it yeah yeah yeah locking is
is but the serialize ability as a
condition doesn't make any sense in this
context because the parties are
interacting through this kind of
incremental mistrusting you know it's
like in these movies where they exchange
Cold War spies across a bridge you know
you can't send one spy over and then
send the other spy because the second
person would just keep their own spy so
you have to do these in there you have
to do these kind of interactive things
which is not serializable because
everybody can see everyone else
so I just wanted to say that there are
the reasons why these asset properties
are so confusing is because they are
pretty together semantic constraints and
implementation constraints and so
something like isolation really has more
to do and consistency for that
consistency it's a semantic constraint
but isolation is actually a constraint
on the implementation of the database
and look together and that's why it's
really confusing oh yeah yeah no I
totally endorse that
of course the other is aliveness assets
can't be locked up forever as close or
can we just think in terms of the edges
that are connecting to things and
transaction data prism I think it
depends on the level that you want to
think I think Barbara is right that here
we're kind of mixing mechanism with with
semantics in some sense and you know
this is part of this this is a side
effect of driving the narration through
this already slightly level confuse
terminology final thing is durability
this is the easier one so a durability
basically says committee transactions to
write crashes now talking about
mechanism here this is a world where
main memory is volatile disks are
non-volatile disks are so inexpensive so
we've got to run around you know writing
things out to disks and so on but really
what this says is that if you say
something committed then it doesn't go
away which is basically the same as
finality you know you you don't we Ord
the database and if you buy into the
libertarian kool-aid this is we also
censorship by regulators corporations
hackers counterparties and so on but I
think our friends at the Calibra are
discovering the that these romantic
ideas of censorship resistance when you
meet with the need to satisfy regulators
you know the outcome is you know can be
confusing
okay so let me wrap up here since I'm
running out of time so what I wanted to
do here was to talk about the post
blockchain world it's ambiguous it could
be post invention of blockchain it could
be the post discovering that block
chains aren't going to solve the world's
problems after all but again this notion
of adversarial Commerce the idea that
untrusted parties need to find a way to
cooperate with each other
mutual benefit despite the fact that
they can't enforce a rules or a trust
one another is basically here to stay
and whether the technology is block
chains or something that we haven't
imagined yet or more likely something we
haven't imagined yet that will be called
block chains when it's a deployed
requires rethinking correctness because
how are we going to prove that our smart
contracts are correct if we are confused
about what it is they're supposed to
accomplish and so you know I started out
with this sort of classical formulation
of atomic transactions again
you know the acid properties are not
ideal but it's a little bit like a
QWERTY keyboard everybody thinks they
understand it so it's easy to explain
things in those terms and then I've
talked about new properties for which we
haven't found a cool a name yet where we
basically use these sort of game
theoretic techniques or great game
theoretic terminology and talk up and
basically you guaranteed that if you can
form the protocol you don't end up end
up worse off and most of the other
properties kind of follow from that
simple requirement that's it
[Applause]
fascinated by this potential theorem
that you are closed just to say you
don't know how to prove but Julia's
right there is no way you can do the
same without an escrow mechanism and I
mean you might be able to prove it using
you can prove almost anything of this
nature there's this FLP approach where
you say well in order to one thing we
can prove for example that you know what
Barbara mentioned is you can use an FLP
like argument to show that if you're in
an asynchronous world there has to be a
single blockchain that that tick
receives all the commits so in the same
way if I can release a if I can transfer
an asset out after promising it to
someone else then similarly you could
keep somebody by transferring it out
immediately before you commit so it's
got to be something that prevents you
from doing that and I bet that kind of
argument can be made a precise although
I can't do it on the spot but you can
always sort of whatever the other pad is
you can always go on a board that one
and get proof to release your escrow
read to me escrow as soon implies that
there's some period of time during which
I lose control of my asset I think
you're absolutely right that part of the
challenge here is to finding exact
formally what escrow means and what
you're pointing out is that it's not
entirely obvious what what escrow means
in this case I'm just sort of like
saying you know can I do an atomic
transaction without putting locks on
data and you know there's optimistic
techniques where you don't lock the data
but when time comes to commit if the
data is interrupted then you don't go
through so I think you know there there
are there's a lot of challenges
and maybe comprehending we want to do it
but worth I bet I prove I can prove that
you need something called escrow if I
get to just define what escrow is
because these two things one is that in
the paper we describe a protocol that is
based on HCl CS but but it's not an
atomic swap because you you can't that
ticket brokering example is not a es
swap but but the economics of the world
are that it's more efficient if you have
a broker who sells tickets you know if I
want to buy a theater ticket I don't you
know walk down the sweet to each a
theater and buy a ticket I go out to
Ticketmaster and buy tickets and I'm
perfectly happy to pay you know a
commission Ticketmaster so if you want
to support a modern economy you have to
be able to support to this kind of
indirect brokering and these complicated
things that cannot be expressed as swaps
no swaps are you know if I have a
chicken and you have a goat we can do a
swap but you know if I want to buy a
theater ticket in Los Angeles I've got
to go through an intermediary and do
something like what I described
swap it's just that on the 2 Chainz
you know Alice and Bob and then Alice
and Carol are the ones forming the
transactions of the HDL sees Alice
doesn't contribute anything to be their
transaction but then everything sort of
proceeds as it normally would when you
say that I was tossing to tribute
anything that's a radical critique of
modern capitalism because you know she's
making the market for them I wouldn't do
it that way because it's too easy to for
them to cheat and cut out the middleman
so you you want to set these things up
so that Alice gets her commission
otherwise you know Bob and Carol are
perfect if they knew how they privacy is
kind of a mechanism I'm talking about
outcomes otherwise
yeah nobody if you tried if you try to
reduce this to atomic swaps what you
would end up with is you would have a
Bob and Carol swapping and then Alice
would be sending one coin and that's not
strongly connected and so by the theorem
I showed you there is a it's not a
strong Nash equilibrium and Bob and
Carol will just totally cut out we have
a protocol where we use it we use
multiple HH l CS but to implement the
deal but is not a swap a protocol you
know I'm defining a swap is a direct
transfer from me to you yes and that's
it but if is me to you and you to a 30
and you take that same asset and send it
to a third party then it's not a swap
because that's not what's what means I'm
defining a swap this way
so the actual difference is that the
swap protocols that were published in
the call themself swap protocols
including one set that I wrote you can
only do one hop direct transfers it has
one hop at a time lightning is not a
swap a protocol it's not no I'm not
saying that nobody has ever done these
things before I'm saying that the this
is not a trivial extension of swaps you
need new machinery and new concepts in
order to talk about this because if you
look at published papers on swaps it's
all direct payments from here to there
that's it
and I'm saying if you do anything more
than that then you could no longer call
it a swap its something something
different yeah you might not be happy
with the terminology but you know I'm
gonna bang my fist on the table and say
know that that's what it means to not
disintermediate the broker that's what
you're cheating right yeah so that is
it's not up it might be I bent ages to
the players to disintermediate the
broker if they could so you you want to
set up the because if they're called the
heating they'll they lose you can
connect where you want and there's no
there's no attempt to protect we broke
up but you do you find some well qualify
as a broker in the payment
sorry in the payment that works in the
readiest
so Alice in this case she cannot lose
money honest like fidelity protecting
yeah sure but here Alice is entitled to
have some commission the goal of the
protocol and somehow he finds them
correctly the Nash equilibrium is set up
in a way that it's going to be in the
best interest of every player if the
deal concludes at all okay to actually
play that Commission to the middle
person the Allyson in this case and I
don't think I think that's a new
question and I use a solution to
slightly different question
would you agree it could be because I
think the lighting network was not
analyzed in the game theoretic way I'm
glad I provoked a discussion but I don't
wanna leave everyone else sitting here
with you know refreshments and bathrooms
and so on out there so thanks again
[Applause]